[Music]
everyone is watching here from words of
gaming that I'm here with sandy from
Yacht Club games talk about so night
hockey dungeon how you don't say sandy
pretty well how are you doing good good
so it's a little about someone a pocket
dungeon it's like a spin-off of the
originals overnight or something like
that right yeah we're super excited we
just announced pocket dungeon yesterday
shuffle my pocket dungeon is coming to
you as a collaboration co-development
game between Yacht Club games and vine
and yeah it's it's a roguelike puzzle
game where it's like a fresh take on the
shovel knight universe so we're hoping
people like it awesome awesome so what
can we expect from Pocket dungeon or
maybe like new enemies or obvious a new
way to play the game right entirely yep
we've never done a puzzle game before a
lot of familiar enemy is a lot of
familiar characters you so there's a
single-player mode that takes you kind
of linearly through a bunch of puzzle of
bouts against a bunch of enemies you
collect upgrades along the way you fight
bosses and then we've also got some
special features like you can play as a
lot of your favorite bosses like king
named all night you know
treasure night they all have a
capability is speaking it speaking of
those those what kind of callbacks in
some of my fans expect from pocket in it
yeah a lot of them you're gonna probably
encounter most of the the bosses from
the other shop like campaigns you'll get
to play as a lot of your favorite
characters a lot of the enemies make
returns so there's some new stuff too
but we want to keep that as a surprise I
would say yeah yeah cool so now you
talked about a little bit about what
some night plugin is just talk a little
about game play so can you break down a
little bit of what the players going
through so what you're doing right now
is shovel knight you're your method of
attacking is by bumping into characters
when you bump into them that's
essentially your attack and you do
damage but they also do reciprocal
damage to you so if you hit like a
skeleton or we call it a bone playing if
you hit a bone playing it's gonna damage
you back so there are things you can do
to mitigate the amount of damage you
take when you take damage you can
quickly go grab a potion that might that
will hopefully be dropping down from
above
and that'll refill your health you can
also get upgrades and items that all
like prevent you from taking a certain
amount of damage or like half here did
the damage you take or you know there's
a lot of mechanics of this a lot of
mechanics yeah there's it's pretty deep
you can kind of create custom builds by
getting certain upgrades that you prefer
along the way oh really that's pretty
cool so how would that carry over to
like later parts of the game because
it's gonna get more challenging
right they get more challenging yep so
you're gonna want to collect gold you're
gonna want to make sure and keep you
know create clusters of enemies so when
you destroy them you're gonna get like
bonus gems out of that right so you're
gonna get more gold for the bigger like
combo chains you do you collect gold
you're gonna go into a shop basically
you're gonna come to shops spend the
gold on upgrades the upgrades will carry
with you and like persists throughout
your journey and that's how you build
your character perfect perfect
so southern ice is very distinct for its
art style and just its overall tone and
style how is it dabbing that to a pocket
dungeon style gameplay like it's been a
lot of fun we love seeing shovel knight
depicted in you know different artistic
styles vine is an incredible artist and
designer and so he kind of set the pace
for us and we've helped you know create
some new characters that are gonna be
exclusive to this game like puzzle night
which was a new character we announced
yesterday so puzzle night was like a
collaboration design between our
development teams and yeah it's been
it's been a lot of fun
perfect perfect so how many of you have
been working on this game and so it's
being developed by vine which is
includes a handful of developers Yacht
Club
kind of helping out in more of a level
design and polish capacity so it's the
shovelknight IP and we're making sure
that like all the characters are
represented correctly and you know we'll
have say and you know maybe how the
flare rod from the original shovelknight
game might you know play as an upgrade
or an item that you collect things like
that but right well it looks and sounds
fantastic
so one can players actually get a chance
to play it no release date just yet so
we just announced the game is in
development yesterday so hopefully
people here at PAX will enjoy you know
getting their hands on it and yeah stay
tuned for new news and updates
throughout the coming year sure for sure
well again it's looking fantastic thanks
so much for your time and what platforms
are we looking at for someone right here
nothing announced just yet for platforms
but what it's playing on at the show
floor here is on Nintendo switch perfect
perfect thank you so much
that's tormach signing up for Lords
gaming dotnet here with some night
Pocket dungeon
you
[Music]